i was knocked out but just by the novel
and the
originality of the characters and the
settings and how visual and cinematic it
felt to me but also because um
i grew up on a goat farm until i was 11
years old
and
had some very similar parental figures
in my life
um and so i could i could understand and
relate to ellis's story and that was
that was definitely part of the
compulsion for me to make this film my
feeling was there was so much texture
and atmosphere and um
and so many little details that uh were
in the novel that we couldn't bring into
the script um and i just felt like it
couldn't be anything but helpful for
them to have a sense of the characters
backstories and um
to have a you know a broader sense of
the world i mean when the actors come
they have a couple days to rehearse and
we shot the film in 24 days but if you
have a book it can really you know
immerse them in the world in a way that
you can with the limited time you have
i was on a flight coming from or going
to sundance and the original producer on
this part the man one of the key
producers on ericopolof was on the
flight to sundance next to me and we
just started talking
and at the time i was running the lit
department at the gersh agency
as an agent
and when i got back um eric had sent me
the script and sent me chris's reel
and uh i read the script and i fell in
love with the script and then i looked
at his reel with a number of great
commercials he had directed
and met chris and said i want to
represent you i want to sell you as a
director and i want to get this movie
made and
then that was probably the first three
years of and then four four years ago i
actually um
started my own company which was a
management production company and we all
know as a manager i can produce
and so i got to be
more involved in putting the financing
together with our partners and
that's it we really wanted digital and
we went with this uh newer camera the
alexa which really uh helped the whole
the daylight feel the whole thing
whereas a lot of digital in the past
has just been maybe looked okay at night
time but in the daytime really
didn't show the love that we uh were
able to get out of um everywhere that we
shot it's it's to see duchovny in a role
that we haven't seen him in anything
like before
uh and have you know amazing soulful
actress like vera farmiga it just
it takes what could be sort of a wacky
silly story with any other cast and
really grounds it the script was great
and it was a magnet for the actors but
actors after they
connect with the material they want to
meet the director and he was a first
timer but it was so clear his vision was
so clear for this is having grown up in
the goat farm being connected to the
material i just every actor i think want
to do the movie not just because of the
material but because of what he was
going to bring to it you know i didn't
have that much time to rehearse um so
rather than sitting around a table
reading script which is not my style
anyway um it was really about
just experience immersing the actors
experientially in the story so i sent to
company and graham phillips who played
ellis right after they got off the
airplane in tucson i sent him into the
mountains to go trekking
with our goat wrangler and um we had a
new age healer come to the house where
we shot and
conduct a sound healing workshop so
those singing bowls that you saw in the
movie that was part of an improvisation
that we did during rehearsal so for me
it was just about getting them into the
world and
and also just talking about her
impressions of the novel
but they're pros david duchovny and vera
farmiga especially having directed
independent films before they
they get it